well the spread of the corona virus is a
global event affecting every country in
the world political leaders are being
measured by their response to the crisis
and among them is Germany's Chancellor
Angela Merkel she's due to step down
from a role before it the next general
election but thanks to rising public
approval ratings over her handling of
the crisis there are calls for Merkel to
continue in the job for now that seems
highly unlikely but could the crisis
upend
Angler Merkel's future plans here's more
as capitals around the world have
largely absorbed the initial shock
covered 19 has dealt their societies the
outlook for the future differs greatly
between world leaders I've just signed
an executive order temporarily
suspending immigration into the United
States this will ensure that unemployed
Americans of all backgrounds will be
first in line for jobs as our economy
reopens so this struggle to start
opening up for business is a risk that I
will take if it gets worse it's on me
you month nobody likes to hear it but
this is the truth we are not in the
final phase of this pandemic we are only
at the start of it and we will have to
live with this virus for a very long
time Angela Merkel's sober science
driven leadership on the final stretch
of her last term in office see some
wanting her to stay beyond her announced
retirement in 2021 Angela Merkel is is a
great European and a great friend of
Poland so from my own point of view you
know we need to clone angular Merkel and
have someone similar running Germany let
me tell you straight that is not going
to happen
mainly because Angela Merkel has ruled
it out many times but also because her
own CDU party isn't keen on a makkal
reload we're not discussing this now or
in the future
and while Merkel's popularity ratings
have risen so has the sense that
after 16 years it will be time for a
change at the Chancellery I can't
imagine any other candidate but after so
many years it could be time for a change
not for Vince I'm glad when she's
finally gone corona or not but what
Corona has changed overnight is the
perception of Angela Merkel in her final
term within the space of just a few
weeks she's gone from lame-duck
chancellor to one of the few world
leaders speaking in the name of science
so corona staying with our societies for
now is just as safe an assumption is
Angela Merkel leaving when her term is
up in autumn 2021